on parle donc loisir pour débuter à
cette édition du 7 suite avec les deux
représentants régionals de la Fédération
Française tournoi national de Black ball
du 9 au 12 mai au clés sousbois les deux
responsables sont donc avec nous et vous
allez nous expliquer ce qu'est le black
ball pour commencer le black ball c'est
un jeu de billard déjà on joue avec des
billes jaunes et rougge et on termine
par une noire le principe est tout
simple c'est soit rentrer les jaunes
soit rentrer les rouges et la noire pour
gagner c'est un moment particulièrement
important pour la discipline ce
rendez-vous phare c'est un rendez-vous
phare qui est organisé ben en fait c'est
le dernier rendez-vous avant le
championnat de France c'est la Coupe de
France ou c'est le dernier national en
même temps ou c'est les dernières
qualification qui s'opère sur le
classement national pour les championnat
de France qui auront lieu fin juin à
Alby comment se déroule la compétition
en elle-même le jour de la compétition
il y a des éliminations directes que va
découvrir le public donc la compétition
de la Coupe de France en elle-même même
est en élimination directe où toutes les
catégories sont mélangées il n'y a qu'un
tout de catégorie et un par équipe
et donc tout se passe par élimination
directe avec les finales le les finales
DESP équipe le jeudi soir vendredi soir
le vendredi soir avec les finales
individuelles en même temps alors tout
cela est très sérieux on va des images
d'autres éditions de de de cette
compétition le le billard c'est souvent
un loisir le soir entre amis on va dire
mais non là c'est très sérieux c'est ce
que vous nous dites ce soir il y a une
compétition une fédération c'est
réglementé le billard est reconnu comme
un sport on fait partie des sports non
olympique mais on espère être olympique
un jour hein ce serait notre notre but
mais le le le principe c'est de pouvoir
s'amuser tout en faisant de la
compétition et il faut pas croire c'est
fatiguant alors pourquoi c'est fatigant
le bère on est debout on reste pendant
des heures debout à jouer et c'est vrai
que la matche peut durer 1 heure 1h3
voire plus quand on est en équipe ça
durer jusqu'à 3h h depuis quand vous
faites du billard respectivement chacun
donc pour ma part moi c'est ma 5e année
et la première en tant que responsable
au sportif d'accord pour une petite
pression supplémentaire vous n'aviez pas
assz d'adrénaline juste en étant joueur
et moi ça 25 ans 25 ans alors pourquoi
pourquoi le billard est-ce qui vous
j'arrêté le billard quand j'ai faisé du
triathlon du triathlon j'ai eu un
problème au niveau des rotules j'ai dû
arrêter le sport et je me suis retrouvé
vers un autre sport moins physique
disons moins endurant surtout qui était
le billard parce qu'il y en avait dans
mon lycée puis ça me plaisait alors
c'est moins physique le bar moins
physique au niveau ben à coup je parle
au niveau des des muscles c'est physique
parce que c'est on reste debout mais il
y a pas il y a pas de comment dire au
niveau des c'est pas les mêmes muscles
qui travaillent c'est pas les mêmes
muscles mais quels sont les qu'apportte
au final cette pratique de cette
discipline qui est un sport ce que vous
nous dites en fait c'est plus tourner un
petit peu vers la réflexion du jeu
d'échec de l'échec des échecs c'est en
c'est beaucoup de réflexion et c'est
beaucoup de au niveau mental ce qui joue
beaucoup h al je VI sur la compétition
qui va se dérouler du au 12 mai au clés
sous-bois c'est une étape c'est-à-dire
qu'il y a d'autres rendez-vous là un
petit peu quels sont les les différents
compétiteurs qui vont être présents
est-ce que ce sera un enjeu
particulièrement important est-ce que
beaucoup de choses vont se jouer sur
cette manche qui se déroulera au clé ça
c'est la dernière étape surtout donc de
ce fait les j tout tout est joué déjà ou
pas non pas tout n'est pas joué sur sur
la tête de classement ben ça va jouer ce
weekend parce que bah les les on va dire
les 10 15 premiers sont très très serrés
au niveau au niveau ranking donc ben
selon qui va gagner ce weekend qui va
faire telle place ou telle place on sait
pas qui sera premier il y a beaucoup de
compétiteurs de très haut niveau qui
sont présents en France oui il y a les
champions du monde en titre sachant que
la France rendre du championnat d'Europe
là où les féminines sont championnes
d'Europe en titre et Champion du monde
en titre du mois d'octobre nous avons
des les moins de 18 ans qui sont
vice-champions d'Europe vicechampion du
Monde l'équipe homme qui était
championne du monde au mois d'octobre et
les moins de 23 qui sont V champion du
monde donc il y aura du très haut niveau
et en féminine la championne du monde et
d'Europe en titre et alors au milieu de
tout ça quels sont les représentants du
club de votre club notre club il y a
donc on a trois représentants qui font
partie de l'équipe de France donc Sarah
chapisalom qui faisait partie de
l'équipe de France féminine monsieur you
dafit Monsieur spenevic William qui font
partie de l'équipe vétéran qui n'ont pas
eu titre cette année mais qui sont Mme
champion du monde en 2010 ils ont des
chances véritablement sur la compétition
oui oh oui sont pour ça vousoulez voy y
arriver à quelle place bah disons qu'ils
sontê tout tê tous test de série donc
dans les dans les dans les 15 20
premiers il y a il y a une un vrai enjeu
au sein du département des evelines ou
est-ce que c'est votre votre club qui
domine un petit peu les débats bah
disons qu'il y a deux gros clubs qui est
le club de la queue et le club de de
viroflé ce sont les clubs coorisateurs
de cette manifestation où il y a de très
très bons joueurs dans chaque club et
c'est vrai que vous nêes pas du même
club on n pas du même club voilà alors
justement je vais peut-être vous
demander également pour vous dans votre
club quels sont les représentants parce
qu'on a vu là tout de suite vous avez
tiré la la couverture à vous on va la
ramener vers le centre é Plô de vutre
côté à présent donc nous sur le club de
la cue leselin on a peu de représentants
puisqu'on est moins nombreux on a un
club plus jeune puisque le club de
virofflé a une bonne dizaine d'années à
10 ans 10 ans cette année 10 ans cette
année euh nous nous sommes un club
affilié Fédération Française de billard
depuis 3 ans maintenant
donc beaucoup moins de joueurs sur le
niveau niveau on va dire quasi
équivalent puisqu'on a aussi d'autres
très bons joueurs mais qui ne sont pas
assez anciens dans la
discipline pour être qualifiés sur les
équipes de France pour nous représenter
au niveau international mais c'est
l'ambition mais c'est l'ambition voilà
dès que vous aura un petit peu plus
d'expérience ça doit arriver il y a une
rivalité entre les deux clubs oui parce
qu'en fait ce sont B sur l'ensemble des
clubs de d'î- de France on va dire ce
sont B les 10 premières places sont
tenues par les deux clubs à peu près à
part une ou deux places par le club de
morpa mais sinon le reste est sur les
deux clubs si vous aimez la rivalité
l'enjeu autour du billard -vous aux clés
sous bois et justement êtes-vous amateur
de billard c'est la question que nous
avons posé aujourd'hui micro trottoir
mélodie Locar j'ai jamais joué j'ai mis
l'occasion franchement d'abord je savais
même pas que c'était un sport hein
ensuite là dites-moi comment on trouve
un billard dans le coin il faut il faut
s'en occuper sérieusement c'est un peu
comme le jeu des échecs il faut faut
pratiquer quoi faut pratiquer le plus
fréquemment possible de manière à
acquérir la la maîtrise est-ce que
d'ailleurs il y a des femmes qui jouent
au billard je sais pas non plus ok j'ai
l'impression que c'est réservé un petit
peu aux autres le billard français c'est
je préfère oui je préfère c'est quand
même surtout les trois bandes faut avoir
l'esprit géométrique et et puis bon
c'est un sport de détente aussi un petit
peu j'aime bien la technicité de ce jeu
c'est beaucoup plus compliqué qu'on quoi
il s'agit pas de lancer des petites
boules comme ça et de taper dedans dans
le temps les gens jouent beaucoup au
billard alors au niveau des grands-pères
par exemple tous les dimanches ils
allaient faire un billard dans les
villages c'est une activité culturelle
maintenant c'est un peu tombé en
désuétude non en désuétude est-ce qu'il
y a que des grand-pères qui jouent au
billard bah non malheureusement
heureusement que non heureusement que
non parce que nous av quand même pas mal
de petits jeunes dont un petit jeune qui
fait partie de la Ligue qui fait partie
de notre commission qui nous a
représenté dans les moins de 18 ans au
niveau de de l'équipe de France qui est
son vichampionne d'Europe donc et
Corentin et Moné qui fait qui s'occupe
de toute la partie informatique de la
Ligue au niveau du Black ball on a aussi
entendu au cours du micro trottoir qu'il
fallait avoir l'esprit géométrique
est-ce qu'on quand on est fort en
mathématiques ça aide bah ça aide parce
que quand on est on se retrouve Snooky
c'est qu'on voit pas sa bille de couleur
directement mais il faut bien pouvoir
sortir par une bande pour pouvoir aller
la toucher ou la rentrer une certaine
logique VO certaine logique et ça les
mat la géométrie rentre en ligne de
compte la compétition débute le UF où on
est la préparation vous êtes en train de
tout finaliser d'installer parce que
c'est important il y a une quarantaine
de tables il y a 40 tables 39 tables
exactement les billards sont tous
montés on est parti tout à l'heure pour
venir sur le plateau il resta quatre à
monter il y a toute l'infrastructure
nourriture à monter aussi parce qu'
quand même tr 300 à 400 personnes à à
nourrir sur 4 jours et on voit les
images de la préparation c'était cet
après-midi c'est au gymnase gillardi sur
la commune tout à fait et donc là toute
la partie de Mar reste la partie réglage
des billards la mise à niveau et toute
la partie mise en place étap importante
ah oui c'est si c'est pas droit ça
marche pas effectivement ça ça va
compliquer un petit peu la compétition
vous participerez chacun oui avec quelle
quelle ambition quelle catégorie bah moi
personnellement je je joue en équipe sur
la Coupe de France donc jeudi en Coupe
de France individuelle
et je joue à partir de samedi matin sur
les régionaux donc organisation
participation en plus les journées
seront bien remplies et pour vous et
pour ma part donc moi je ne jouerai pas
sur la Coupe de France ni en équipe ni
en individuel je ne jouerai qu'à partir
de vendredi soir sur le tournois
national sur les éliminatoires du
tournoi national et sur le reste du
weekend de l'arbitrage bonne chance à
vous pour cette compétition bonne ch au
club et puis à l'ensemble des
compétiteurs ils sont plus de 300 à se à
se présenter au cours de ces différentes
journée merci à vous